hey everybody it's Jesse and I'm making
this video today from a bunk bed this is
my friend Ambrose Oh in my robot hand I
really love robot this is my son and
today I want to talk a little bit about
what I did to prepare for my interviews
so the last two videos on my channel
were about my Google interview
specifically and then another video just
more in general my whole experience of
interviewing so I had several questions
about what I did to prepare so I'm gonna
go over some of the websites I used and
books and resources and I'm gonna let
you know which ones I think were the
most helpful so just to start out I
interviewed for front-end developer
positions front-end engineer software
engineer positions so and so my it was
more front-end based for me all of my
interviews interview questions and my
preparation so depending on whether your
front-end back into full stack and what
languages you use it's maybe a little
bit different but one service that I
think was really valuable was called
pram it's a PR a MP I'll make sure I put
links to everything I talked about in
the description so [ __ ] is a service
where you sign up and you get paired up
with someone else for a timeslot
so I think it was like an hour time slot
in the first half hour one of you takes
the role of the interviewer and the
other one is the interviewee and then
for the second half of the timeslot you
switch places so it gives you not only
do you have a practice question but you
also have a time limit
and you have someone else that's asking
a question that you have to explain
yourself to that was really helpful they
have it broken down by different
categories so you can just do front-end
related stuff because of that it stood
out as being really unique and offering
something that some of the other
resources don't have any experience
experience if you don't experience for
the interviews then I definitely
recommend pram
I they may have like free tier I'm not
sure I think it is a paid service but
there may be some way to get some free
things I'll find out and input more info
in the description so the next thing
that I used that was very very helpful
was a book called cracking the coding
interview and I know I mentioned this in
some other videos and I mentioned it to
some of you that asked me questions
directly it's a huge book it has a lot
of information in it it was written by a
woman who actually interviewed a lot of
people at Google it goes through and
explains what interviewers are thinking
what they're looking for when they
actually interviewed you and just being
able to get into that that mindset of
what interviewers are actually thinking
helped me so much it helps me you know
there's there's so many things you could
talk about a focus on when you're in an
interview so just knowing
what rygel that's right okay there's
also a ton of practice problems and
explanations of data structures and
algorithms so if you were going for a
more general software engineer position
or a back-end position then those
practice problems would help you a lot
for me it wasn't that helpful because
most of my questions were specifically
front-end JavaScript related so it was
it was still cool to go over some of
that info don't I don't have a computer
science background so a lot of it was
new to me so I'm sure it'll be helpful
to me at some point but just wasn't so
much for for the interview so if you're
going for front-end stuff then I think
it's safe to skip over a lot of those
sections of that book the next resource
that I use and and this is probably a
little bit more front-end specific is
free code camp so free code camp has
some practice interview questions and
they also have some kind of less
difficult JavaScript algorithm
challenges so I think that's a great way
to refresh your JavaScript knowledge
should if you already have a job where
you're not coding that much all the time
you want to get in the habit of coding
as much as you can so I'd I highly
recommend free code camp for a variety
of things but in this case for sure for
your figure
interview prep and another resource
another resource that I used was
JavaScript data structures and
algorithms book I'll put the the
official title and link to that below I
ended up getting the the e-book so I had
that on my phone so I got the hard copy
of the crack in the coding interview but
when I was in a situation where I didn't
have a hard copy you know but I always
had my phone on me then I could always
look at that so that helped me because
it was JavaScript specific which is the
language that I was being tested in so
that was it was easier for me to
understand the example problems than
what I was seeing in cracking the coding
interview it was just another
explanation of some of those data
structures and algorithms which like I
said ended up not helping me that much
because I didn't really get questions
about it but if you are going for
something that's more full stack
position or back in position you may get
asked questions about that so I highly
recommend that and I recommend that for
whatever books you're using I think it
would be a good idea to have an
electronic copy of the book so even if
you were if you like hard copies that's
great
if you can only find it in hardcopy
that's fine and sometimes especially
when you're looking at code it's a lot
easier to just have a hard copy
sometimes but having that on my phone
was so useful you know I post on waiting
in line waiting at the doctor's office
you know I didn't feel like I was
wasting time I could always look at that
in practice so it just kind of always
kept it in my mind and I think that's
that's really helpful when you you just
need to be able to always be thinking
about code
it just it makes it so much easier when
you're actually on the spot in the
interview you only have a short amount
of time you know you're probably a
little bit nervous yeah it's the Master
Sword from Zelda I mean not the Master
Sword but you know a good replica I
think like like you would approach let's
say a foreign language language
[Music]
conversation with somebody the same
over-serving even if you didn't have
great resources this is so coded as
often as you could okay little squeaky
mouse no worst weekend as often as you
possibly could
that's gonna be more useful than if you
have great resources the perfect books
the perfect questions and you only
looked over them you know occasionally
[Music]
just practice actually go on the
interview just be be honest okay you
don't have to do you don't have to be
down on yourself you don't have to tell
the interview all the things you don't
know but on the other hand don't claim
that you know things that you don't
because they'll be able to figure it out
really easily make a network request job
is good you say oh yeah I do it all the
time they say okay can you can you do it
for me you know write it on the on the
white well maybe you're stuck right if
you don't really know how to do it so
just be honest you could say you know
what hey I've done it before but I'm a
little rusty on the syntax or you know
what I've never actually had to do that
I kind of know how to how it's done can
I just explain it to you
[Music]
something like that is a little more
acceptable and if you have to just say
listen I've never heard of that before
[Music]
[Music]
thank you so if you don't know admit
that you don't know but then it would be
helpful to say listen like if I had to
do that for my job here's where I would
go to find the answer you know so say I
would I would look this up on mdn or
something like that and then at least
you would you could give some answer
even if you have no idea you've at least
given some answer and said like here's
how I would approach this with this
problem so I think I'm gonna wrap this
video up that was my my advice let me
know what you think if it say goodbye to
everybody on YouTube would you like to
say goodbye that was soggy by me all
right see you later everybody hopefully
this helped and your ideas for what
videos I should do next
until next time have a great day